Die Schweiz:
überwältigende Bergpanoramen,
atemberaubende Natur
und ein „musikalisches“ Nationalsymbol –
das Alphorn.
Dem rund dreieinhalb Meter langen
Instrument zu Ehren
treffen sich jedes Jahr Tausende Alphornfans
in Nendaz im Kanton Wallis.
Ich komme aus Belgien,
dem flämischen Teil.
Ich bin aus Holland.
Ich komme aus Manchester
in Großbritannien.
Ich komme aus Deutschland,
aus Steinheben,
und uns gefällt die Alphorn…
das Alphornspielen.
Und deshalb kommen wir her.
Rund 4000 Alphornbläser
sind in der Schweiz aktiv.
Hier in Nendaz, auf dem größten
Alphornfestival des Landes,
treffen sich 150 Musiker aus der ganzen Welt.
Die meisten von ihnen sind über 50.
Doch es gibt auch junge Instrumentalisten,
die Lust auf das Alphorn haben.
Was sich vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen
tendenziell anbahnt, ist,
dass verschiedene Jüngere auch versuchen,
ein bisschen aus der Folklore rauszukommen,
sondern eher dann eben
ein bisschen in jazzige[n]
oder dann auch in chromatische[n] Tonlagen
zu spielen, sofern das möglich ist.
Je nach Horn können zwölf bis 16 Töne
erzeugt werden –
genug, um auch
zeitgenössische Stücke zu spielen.
Die internationale Gruppe „The Alpine
Sisters“ hat sich darauf spezialisiert.
Man kann natürlich nicht alles spielen.
Aber unseren Stil
können wir durchaus wählen.
Es ist, als hätte man eine Trompete
ohne Ventile.
Wir haben begrenzte Möglichkeiten.
Eine Zeit lang galt Folklore als langweilig.
Aber jetzt scheint es,
als gäbe es ein Comeback.
Und ich glaube, dass Alphornspielen
jetzt wieder richtig cool ist.
Es ist wirklich im Trend.
Ursprünglich war das Alphorn
quasi das „Handy“ der Hirten –
und das nicht nur in Europa.
Auch in Asien wurde es von den meisten
Viehhütern als Kommunikationsmittel genutzt.
Im Verlauf der fast 500-jährigen Geschichte
verstummte das Alphorn
in der Schweiz immer mehr.
Nendaz gilt heutzutage als
Hauptstadt des Instruments.
Hier spielt es fast jeder –
so wie Patricia Monory.
Meine Mutter ist auch Alphornistin.
Sie spielt mit mir in einer Gruppe.
Ich glaube, ich habe damit angefangen,
weil sie es gespielt hat,
und ich dachte,
es ist ein cooles Instrument.
Und jetzt bin ich hier.
Viele Alphornbläser brauchen
auch viele Alphörner.
In der Schweiz gibt es rund 40
der spezialisierten Instrumentenbauer.
Einer von ihnen ist François Morisod.
Zwei Wochen ist er
mit einem Instrument beschäftigt.
Fünf bis acht Jahre muss das Holz der
Schweizer Rottanne trocknen,
ehe er es verarbeiten kann.
Wir wählen einen Baum aus,
der auf nährstoffarmem Boden wächst.
Auf sehr steinigem Untergrund wächst er
sehr langsam und nicht so hoch.
Die Leitungsbahnen im Baum sind sehr eng,
wodurch das Wachstum verlangsamt wird.
Solches Holz suchen wir.
Wir nennen es Klangholz.
Es ist das gleiche Holz, aus dem man Geigen,
Gitarren und ähnliche Musikinstrumente baut.
Mit Stolz [er]halten die Männer
aus Nendaz und Umgebung
auch andere Bräuche aufrecht
wie das sogenannte „Geislechlöpfern“
und das „Treichlern“,
bei dem riesige Kuhglocken geläutet werden.
Der Höhepunkt ist aber
das Gesamtspiel der 150 Alphornbläser.
Und das wird ganz sicher auch
nächstes Jahr so sein, wenn das Festival
im Südschweizer Kanton Wallis
in die 19. Runde geht.